[Music]
margaret
[Music]
i'm sorry
[Applause]
i'm sorry though elevator was out
sorry that probably looks weird it's
time for my warm-ups i'm gonna do this
oh my god
hey deeperino
hey deep what kid
yeah just hang a left
i think it's actually my bad
[Applause]
if you think soups are [ __ ] now you
just want to wear a camo
and what's to stop sergeant ham [ __ ] me
whoa distracted by another bird
whoa you think soup's a [ __ ] now this is
good stuff
how many hijackers looks like three
scrambled f-16s yeah as we speak but
you you think sergeant homeland is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] now
wow this is amazing all right i'm gonna
get this this is
good [ __ ]
oh
i'm a rat
i need a little bit more de niro for me
on this one
just uh you know
yeah i got it
you know you have the job freshly left
[Laughter]
it could be more of a miami
did you know i killed translucent
oh i bought his whole buzz
oh [ __ ] good talk
i'm glad we had this chat the only
reason i'm really here is to have a good
blooper reel
is that it i don't care about the show i
just want to go blooper reel right
that's all i care about really at the
end of the day
you